you guys jobs are to get clicked so it's
like
when you take my quote out of context
and when you just say that if you paint
the picture on the inside out like y'all
are trying to split split us up I'm not
blaming anything on the coaches I'm
never going to blame it he's going to
coach it's never going to blame anything
on my teammates
I will take every whatever happens in
the game I would take all the blame I
don't care to drop pass it should have
been a pass put it on me but
never when you hear anything come out of
my mouth to where I will blame it on
somebody else in this organization my
teammates never will you hear that so I
just want to clear that out and just
know that like
I need to play better that's it Point
Blank if y'all that's that's what I
should have said in the first place